[Musique]
de l'amour wen que dieu a pour les
anglais je n'en sais rien mais je sais
bien qu'ils seront tous bouter hors de
france
excepté ceux qui périront jeanne d'arc
en pleine guerre de cent ans contre les
anglais adorent que le royaume de france
est noyée dans une guerre civile
opposant armagnacs et bourguignons
le destin du roi charles vii se noue
autour de deux femmes exceptionnelles
que tout oppose une vierge
jeanne d'arc et une courtisane agnès
sorel le règne de charles vii
on peut dire qu'il est marqué par les
femmes au moins par deux femmes par
jeanne d'arc qui jaillit dans l'histoire
comme ça de façon quasiment miraculeuse
voire incompréhensible et puis aussi par
une autre femme qui est elle aujourd'hui
entre le miss france ou miss monde ou
miss univers c'est une star c'est la
belle agnès sorel jeanne d'arc passé à
la postérité comme la pucelle d'orléans
au destin tragique entend libérer le
royaume du joug anglais et conduire le
roi à reims pour officialiser son
pouvoir par le sacre
jeanne d'arc est un personnage
éminemment charismatique elle a réussi à
convaincre le futur roi de france de lui
confier un rôle militaire et
d'accompagner les armées du roi de
france notamment pour délivrer la ville
d'orléans
agnès sorel traverse l'histoire comme un
météore
elle conseille le roi dans l'alcôve
inaugurant le statut très convoité de
favorite officielle et donne une
impulsion nouvelle à la vie de cour
la guerre de cent ans conflit séculaire
entrecoupés de trêve oppose français et
anglais elle est l'expression d'une
rivalité féroce entre les dynastie des
valois et des plantagenêts de philippe 6
alloué 11 l'a guère évolué dépassant le
cadre des luttes féodal et des velléités
dynastique
la première période couvre les années
très 137,13 180 elle se divise en deux
temps forts le premier trait 137,13 160
voix une victoire quasi totale les
armées anglaises
alors que le second très 173 180 marques
un renversement du rapport de forces
leurs établissements français et
l'affirmation du pouvoir des valois pour
comprendre les racines complexe de cette
guerre il faut remonter à 1066 date à
laquelle le duc de normandie
guillaume le conquérant devient roi
d'angleterre et fonde une nouvelle
dynastie selon les lois féodal il reste
le vassal du roi de france pour ses
possessions normande et de donc lui
prêter hommage
les ancrages de la royauté anglaise en
france s'étoffe avec l'arrivée au
pouvoir d'andry 2 plantagenêt il ajoute
l'anjou la touraine et par son union
avec une ex reine de france
aliénor l'immense duché d'aquitaine
henry devient alors plus puissant que le
roi de france en son royaume
philippe auguste puis louis 8
parviennent néanmoins à obtenir par les
armes
l'obéissance du roi d'angleterre et à
réduire ses fiefs henri iii hérite à son
tour de l'épineux problème qui a déjà
jeté son oncle richard coeur de lion et
son père jean sans terre sur les champs
de bataille continentaux le traité de
paris signé avec saint louis en 259
semblent aboutir à une solution et henri
iii acceptent de prêter l'hommage lige
au roi de france
pourtant la guyenne reste au centre de
toutes les convoitises et les hostilités
reprennent à l'initiative du roi de
france philippe iv le bel
un mariage entre la fille de ce dernier
isabelle et le roi edward d'angleterre
en 13 108 doit consolider la paix entre
les deux géants mais il va falloir
compter avec les ambitions de leurs
héritiers
edouard iii il ya des partis qui se
regroupent pour que la la couronne
française reste indemne de tout sens
étranger donc la guerre de cent ans en
bas c'est l'exaspération de ce sentiment
avec charles quatre fils de philippe le
bel c'est un la dynastie des capétiens
direct c'est un cousin simple fils de
compte qui accède au trône de france
sous le nom de philippe 6 en 13 128
edouard trois héritiers des capétiens
direct par sa mère et petit fils de
philippe le bel voilà une nouvelle
source de contestation quand philippe 6
multiplie les ingérences en guyenne et
en flandres puis refuse son aide à
edouard iii en guerre contre l'ecosse le
roi d'angleterre revendique
solennellement la couronne de france 7
octobre 13 137 les deux royaumes bascule
alors dans la guerre de cent ans
[Musique]
deux traits 137 à 13 160 l'angleterre
prouve sa suprématie edouard iii
s'assure le contrôle des mers en
détruisant la flotte française lors de
la bataille de lécluse le 24 juin 13140
la succession du duché de bretagne
devient un nouvel enjeu et en 13146 la
grande chevauchée anglaise d'edouard iii
déferle sur la france et sèment la
terreur
le prince noir fils du roi d'angleterre
inflige à philippe 6 une sévère défaite
à crécy calais capitule l'année suivante
offrant à l'angleterre une tête de pont
militaire et commercial de premier choix
[Musique]
en 13 150 une nouvelle génération entre
dans le conflit philippe 6 laisse à son
fils jean ii le bon
un héritage précaires ils se heurtent
aux terribles prince noir qui gouverne
la guyenne et entreprend deux
chevauchées jean 2 et fait prisonnier en
l'affrontant à poitiers en 13,156
l'humiliante paix de calais signé le 24
octobre 13 160 c droit d'angleterre la
souveraineté sur près d'un tiers du
royaume de france
le bras de fer se poursuit mais la
période très 173 180 marques un
renversement du rapport de forces
charles 5 sacré roi de france entrait
164 eridan royaume noyé dans la
confusion des guerres de territoire avec
l'aide du célèbre connétable bertrand du
guesclin
il parvient à réaffirmer le pouvoir des
valois sur le royaume de france
à la mort du roi de france charles de 50
13 180 la guerre entre français et
anglais fait rage depuis quarante trois
à deux jeunes rois sous tutelle ont
hérité du conflit et sont maintenant au
pouvoir
charles ciss de france et richard ii
d'angleterre la fin du 14ème siècle voit
peu à peu le monde médiéval céder sa
place au monde moderne
cette seconde phase de la guerre de cent
ans s'articule comme la première des
conquête anglaise suivie d'un retour en
force de la monarchie française
permettant à chaque royaume de
consolider un territoire qui ressemble à
celui dans lequel les deux nations
vivent encore aujourd'hui en france
charles ciss sombre dans la folie et une
grave crise politique éclater les
princes du sang se disputent alors le
pouvoir d'un côté son unique frère louis
premier d'orléans
de l'autre son oncle paternel le duc de
bourgogne philippe de hardy
à la tête d'un territoire en pleine
expansion par une habile politique de
mariage il obtient la flandre un duché
déjà puissant pendant ce temps en
angleterre richard ii est écarté du
pouvoir par son cousin henri de
lancastre qui parvient à monter sur le
trône sous le nom d'henri iv
[Musique]
les crises de démence de charles ciss se
multiplient en 14 104 jean-sans-peur
arrive à la tête du duché de bourgogne
et poursuit la lutte pour le pouvoir
contre son cousin louis premier
d'orléans qui bénéficie des faveurs
d'isabeau de bavière
c'est en quittant la chambre de la
sulfureuse rennes qu'il est assassiné
par les hommes de jean sans peur en 14
ans est le nouveau duc d'orléans n'a pas
la carrure pour s'opposer à lui c'est
son beau père bernard d'armagnac qui
devient le chef de file d'une opposition
qui contrôle encore la moitié du royaume
paris va devenir le théâtre d'une
tragédie sanglante ou un roi fou
continue d'incarner le pouvoir pendant
que grandit son héritier le futur
charles sept chars le 7
on le sait le 11e enfants de 10 à bo de
bavière et du roi folle charles ciss et
c'est un garçon qui va attendre très
longtemps que son père qui n'est plus en
état de renier car charles si ce n'est
plus en état de renier rendre son âme à
dieu avant de pouvoir lui même prendre
le pouvoir et pendant ce temps là et
bien c'est isabeau de bavière qui assure
une manière de régence
mais elle assure une régence avec deux
factions politiques extrêmement
importantes qui sont les bourguignons le
parti de bourguignons et le parti
armagnac le pays
en plus de la guerre de cent ans est en
proie à une guerre civile entre
armagnacs qui vont devenir les partisans
du roi de france et bourguignons les
alliés des anglais en 14 215 le nouveau
roi d'angleterre henry 5 débarque avec
douze mille hommes dans l'embouchure de
la seine
renouant avec la tradition des grandes
chevauchées de ses prédécesseurs jean
sans peur
le duc de bourgogne laisse faire seuls
les armagnacs vont se dresser sur sa
route
l'affrontement a lieu à azincourt le 25
octobre 14 115 la cavalerie française
est décimée
[Musique]
le roi d'angleterre débarque à nouveau
sur les côtes françaises en 14 77
cette fois-ci et conquiert la normandie
il aimait le siège devant roi charles le
jeune dauphin de france cristallise les
espoirs des armagnacs
il est bien conscient de la démence de
son père qui n'est plus qu'un pantin
entre les mains du puissant ducs de
bourgogne jean sans peur a lié des
anglais charles entre alors en rébellion
paris ne sera pratiquement plus aux
mains du fils du roi de france du
dauphin charles sait bien que il va
devoir le pari est aux mains des
bourguignons et des anglais réunit et
lui va devoir quitter paris piteusement
et venir se réfugier où ça et bien à
bourges puisque on l'appellera le petit
roi de bourges à partir de ce moment là
devant les prétentions grandissante du
roi d'angleterre jean sans peur tant à
plusieurs reprises une conciliation avec
dauphin charles
[Musique]
la dernière entrevue à lui à monteux rô
le 10 septembre 14 sont 19 la rencontre
tourne mal et jean sans peur est
assassiné
[Musique]
les relations sont définitivement rompu
et bourguignons accuse alors charles ii
bâtardise ce qui le prive de légitimité
pour accéder au trône de france à la
mort de jean sans peur
le fils de jean sans peur leduc le
nouveau duc de bourgogne philippe lebon
s'allie au roi d'angleterre henry 5
c'est le début de l'alliance franco
bourguignonne qui va livrer la france le
royaume de france à l'angleterre en vie
cinq consolide son influence en épousant
catherine la fille du roi fouchard le 6
il impose alors en france l'idée d'une
double monarchie deux royaumes distincts
mais un seul droit à partir de la mort
de charles six puisqu'il n'a plus
d'héritier digne de ce nom
sinon son nouveau jambre tout cela est
actée par le traité de troyes signé en
14 ans va isabeau de bavière fait appel
directement aux anglais armée aux
troupes anglaises va promulguer avec
charles ciss le foll le traité trois ans
14 120 qui va déshérités son fils elle
déshérite charles vii pour placer sur le
trône le roi l'angleterre en b 5 meur en
août 14 122 laissant un fils âgé d'à
peine deux ans henry 6 lequel en vertu
du traité de troyes est censé recevoir à
sa majorité les couronnes de france et
d'angleterre
la régence est alors assurée par l'oncle
du jeune roi le duc de bedford qui
gouverne à paris
l'année 14 122 vous êtes aussi la
disparition de charles ciss pour ses
partisans
charles vii est bien le roi légitime
mais encore faut-il officialisé la
fonction par le sacre
au nord le royaume de france est dominé
par l'alliance anglo bourguignonne avec
d'une part le régent duc de bedford
régent du royaume de france au nom de
son neveu en russie ce qui est un tout
jeune enfant et d'autre part le duc de
bourgogne philippe lebon le fils de jean
sans peur qui a fait alliance avec les
anglais ou après le meurtre de son père
à montereau le sud du royaume continue
en revanche à obéir à charles vii
l'ancien dauphin charles c'est ce qu'on
appelle le royaume de bourges
parce qu'il a sa capitale à bourges et à
poitiers la france a donc deux rois et
la guerre reprend contre l'anglais
alors que les combats font rage de 6
janvier 14 212 la célèbre jeanne d'arc
voit le jour dans un petit village de
lorraine du nom de domrémy nul ne peut
alors prédire le destin exceptionnel de
cette petite paysanne jeanne d'arc elle
ressemble est un danger et on était un
peut-être parce que il ya quelque chose
d'extraordinaire devoir de surnaturel à
a constaté que cette petite jeune fille
qui est née de deux paysans de jacques
d'arc à domrémy et d'isabelle rom et sa
maman qui ne savait quasiment pas lire
pas écrire va réussir à bouleverser
l'histoire du monde village de domrémy
sous domination bourguignonne mais
situées à l'intérieur d'une enclave
fidèle aux dauphins la châtellenie de
vaucouleurs n'est pas épargnée par la
guerre
jeanne grandi dans une atmosphère de
violence
à 13 ans pour la première fois il entend
une voix qui lui parle de la misère dans
lequel se trouve le royaume on sait que
la petite jeanne sur le coup de 13 14 15
ans à des voix chacun de ces des voies
de saint michel sainte catherine
sainte-marguerite des voix qu'il lui
dise voilà on a choisi toi parce qu'il
faut que tu fasses quelque chose il faut
que tu ailles voir le roi de france faut
que tu lui dises que il doit être
vraiment roi de france et c'est toi qui
vas y aller persuadé qu'aucun français
digne de ce nom ne peut adhérer à la
double monarchie
charles vii réunit une armée de fidèles
pour poursuivre la lutte contre les
anglais et la guerre civile contre les
bourguignons l'armée anglaise commandé
par le chant de lancastre duc de bedford
et puissante et organisée en 14 128 m
ford décide de passer la loire et
assiègent orléans avec pour objectif de
soumettre bourges et de capturer charles
vii
dunois lebastard d'orléans fils
illégitime du défunt duc louis premier
d'orléans assure tant bien que mal le
ravitaillement jane vient d'avoir 17 ans
et elle ne peut plus ignorer les voix
qui lui commandent de réagir
le 12 février 14 129 accompagné par son
oncle elle demande une audience auprès
du seigneur de vos couleurs
elle s'en va d'abord à tout à côté à
vaucouleurs voir le capitaine de la
place richard ii baudricourt et elle lui
dit il faut que j'aille voir le roi de
france que qui-vive croire actuellement
à chinon wolof évidemment mettez donc
mettons nous à la place du capitaine qui
éclate de rire en voyant cette petite
gamine mal fagotée lui parler d'eux des
choses de la royauté du royaume de
france et un 1 6 et insistent et c'est
ça la puissance de jeanne d'arc c'est
qu'elle a une force de persuasion un
pouvoir de conviction phénoménal c'est
bien que au bout de trois rencontres
monsieur baudricourt lui dit écoutez il
ya quelque chose qui m'échappe mais ça
me dépasse c'est plus fort que moi et il
va lui donner un petit équipage
il va lui dire les va va et advienne que
pourra
[Musique]
et
seigneur de vaucouleurs lui remettent
une lettre d'introduction et l'ue
attache une escorte pour se rendre à
chinon trouver chars le 7 que jeanne
continue d'appeler le dauphin tant qu'il
n'est pas sacré jeanne d'arc avec les
voix qu'elle a entendu de saint michel
de sainte-marguerite etc on lui a dit le
roi charles vii et le roi de france il
faut qu'ils soient couronnés à reims
donc elle bondit vers le roy on le sait
à chinon fait entrevue de chinon entre
jeanne d'arc et charles vii est
considéré par beaucoup d'historiens
comme un tournant dans la guerre de cent
ans dans chauveau chiant pays
bourguignon jeanne prend des habits
d'homme le 25 février elle entre dans
chinon ou une première épreuve l'attend
on sait que le roi s'était camouflé dans
la foule il avait essayé de passer dans
le passé inaperçu et qu'elle s'est
dirigé vers lui automatiquement jeanne
désigne le roi sans hésiter charles et
son conseil se décide donc à la recevoir
la scène ne s'est pas passé tout à fait
comme ça en fait il ya eu deux entrevues
et les historiens ont scindé ses deux
entrevues en une entrevue mythique et
légendaire lors de la première entrevue
le dauphin charles a reçu jeanne d'arc
36 conique et le dauphin charles qui n'a
pas été complètement convaincu par la
prestation de jeanne d'arc l'a envoyé à
poitiers là où résidaient ses
conseillers ses théologiens pour que
jeanne d'arc soient interrogés et que sa
bonne foi soit vérifiée des théologiens
qui vont lui poser les questions et
surtout un examen de corps parce qu'il
faut savoir si il s'agit vraiment d'une
femme et il suffit s'agit de savoir
aussi si si elle est plus elle est en
effet après l'examen et bien je la
petite jeanne s'avère être une pucelle
et on sait que dans l'histoire elle
restera comme la pucelle d'orléans bien
sûr
cet examen devant les théologiens va
durer trois semaines
jeanne d'arc se dit investi d'une
mission divine et l'entente bouter les
anglais hors de france et promet des
miracles
[Musique]
or
le conseil de sages de la juge il fold
est corrompu par le diable et compte
tenu de la situation dramatique dans
laquelle se trouve le royaume
il autorise le dauphin a accédé à sa
requête lui donner une escorte armée
pour la conduire à orléans suite à cette
mise à l'épreuve à poitiers jeanne d'arc
revient à la forteresse le 27 mars 1429
et comme elle a apporté aux conseillers
du roi
toutes les réponses qu'ils attendaient a
lieu à ce moment-là la forteresse de
chillon la seconde entrevue probablement
dans la grande salle de la forteresse au
cours de laquelle le futur roi présente
jeanne d'arc à la cour et l'investît
officiellement de ses missions et
notamment des livres et le royaume de
france
la réputation de jeanne d'après cède
elle dicte une lettre à l'intention des
anglais et des sommes de quitter la
france
la première image de jeanne véhiculée
par les partisans de charles vii et
celle de la bergère de domrémy afin de
mieux coller à l'imagerie biblique de
son vivant
jeanne devient une véritable icône des
prophéties évoque bientôt une vierge en
armes venues libérer la france du joug
anglais on évoque son parcours de vos
couleurs à poitiers en passant par
chinon en l'agrémentant d'épisodes
merveilleux
[Musique]
faut toujours rappeler quand on parle de
van darc que ce qu'ils avaient de
curieux c'est que la cour de charles vii
était plutôt dépravé plutôt mauvaise
chrétienne d'hier et aujourd'hui et
le clan de de la vertu c'était plutôt le
clan adverse et c'est ça le la
singularité de de jeanne d'arc c'est
qu'elle apporte une image de pureté au
clan au camp le plus le moins vertueux
en apparence après une bref préparation
militaire jeune reçoit une arme et une
armure et un étendard blanc élan choisi
la scène des images de la vierge et du
christ lors du jugement dernier
bénissons des fleurs de lys porté par
les deux archange surmontée de
l'inscription jésus maria la route
d'orléans est ouverte
grâce à l'énergie du batardeau relayant
le siège s'éternise durant l'hiver et la
cité résistent aux assauts anglais mais
la situation devient particulièrement
éprouvante pour la population qui craint
de devoir bientôt se nourrir de rats
la ville est prise d'assaut les anglais
ont décidé de faire une ceinture une
ceinture hermétique autour d'orléans
pour éviter que l'on puisse en sortir et
qu'on puisse rentrer mais jeanne d'arc
réussit donc à apporter des vivres et va
franchir toutes ces petites bastille que
les anglais avaient placé autour de la
ville famars orléans envisage de se
soumettre aux ducs de bourgogne
devant le refus de bedford son allié
bourguignon retire ses troupes
la pucelle prend les armes à tour son
étendard lui confère le statut de chef
d'armée c'est pourtant sans commandement
effectif qu'elle fait partie de ce
contingent de secours qui doit permettre
de libérer orléans
jeanne impose une discipline qu'on
attendrait d'une armée aux croisades sur
la route quelques miracles semble lever
les doutes des hommes de guerre qui
l'accompagnent le convoi se présentent
bientôt devant la ville une diversion
est organisée par le défenseur de la
cité et le vendredi 29 avril et 14 129
jeanne précédé de son étendard fait son
entrée triomphale dans la cité sur un
cheval blanc
mais les capitaines qui l'accompagnent
tiennent la pucelle à l'écart des
stratégies militaires et attaques dans
vingt deux dispositifs anglaise une
seconde offensive a mené avec le
concours de jeanne leur apporte enfin la
victoire
alors que rien ne pouvait penser me
laissait à penser qu'elle était un grand
stratège elle va nuire c'est là qu'il
faut attaquer c'est là qu'il faut c'est
la tour c les tournelles qu'il faut
prendre etc etc
parce que dieu me l'a dit et en effet
tous accompli comme dieu le lui a dit en
quelques jours les anglais sont vaincus
et contraints de se replier
transcendés par cette victoire jeanne
conduit le dernier assaut qui met
l'armée anglaise en déroute
mais blesse la pucelle à l'épaule 8 mai
14 129 le miracle se produit orléans
libéré les succès militaires qu'on
attribue à jeanne d'arc ne doivent pas
être attribué seulement à jeanne d'arc
il procède également les chefs
militaires recrutés par charles vii
mais jeanne d'arc a eu un rôle
charismatique un rôle de meneuse
d'hommes en quelque sorte qui a
véritablement enflammé le courage et le
la vaillance des soldats français
jeanne d'arc compte bien tirer profit de
cet élan l'armée de charles vii attire
de nouveaux partisans et l'étendard de
la pucelle de nouveaux fidèles autour du
bâtard d'orléans de l'aïr et de gilles
de rais l'alchimie se produit entre
l'innocence de jeanne la violence de ses
compagnons d'armes qui vont inscrire
leur nom dans la légende
[Musique]
à
la levée du siège d'orléans initie une
série de victoires d'abord la libération
des places de la loire comme
meung-sur-loire beaugency et jargeau
puis c'est la grande bataille rangée de
patay les envahisseurs opte maintenant
pour la fuite
jeanne convainc ses capitaines de
continuer à les harceler contraint une
bataille rangée
les anglais cherchent un terrain
favorable qu'il trouve près de pater
forts de leurs expériences heureuses a
créé six ans 13146 puis à zinc ou en 14
il conduisait de la même stratégie les
éclaireurs français repères l'ennemi et
quand l'avant-garde perfore sur le côté
les lignes de défense anglaise
la déroute est totale ce triomphe est
encore attribués à jeanne d'arc pourtant
resté à l'arrière bien malgré elle la
situation militaire est définitivement
renversé et la nouvelle se répand à
travers tout le royaume
charles 7 promet alors l'aministie à
toutes les villes qui avaient oublié
qu'elle était française
après auxerre le 3 juillet ces trois une
semaine plus tard qu'ils acceptent de
reconnaître ses erreurs tout un symbole
pour la ville de l'humilier en traiter
de 14 120 rue encore psychologie et
persuasion et conviction candan 3 3
était une place forte solide et bien
elle va voir le gouverneur de la place
forte de 3 en lui disant écoutez ça
risque on va mettre 3 feu et à sang on
va envahir la ville
alors que on peut passer paisiblement si
vous nous accordez si vous nous héberger
quelque temps et le gouverneur qui
préférait que la ville ne fut pas piller
va en effet céder aux injonctions de la
petite jeanne d'arc et ensuite direction
reims la semaine suivante de 17 juillet
14 129 le dauphin est couronné à reims
sous le nom de charles septe la dynastie
des valois est sauvé grâce à jeanne
d'arc
il semble d'ailleurs que le peuple
rassemblés sur le parvis de la
cathédrale de reims acclament davantage
la pucelle que le roi de france
ce dernier doit maintenant conquérir
paris
la guerre civile continuer à enflammer
le royaume
paris est toujours aux mains des
bourguignons et des anglais bedford a eu
le temps de réorganiser la défense de la
ville jeanne d'arc veut profiter de
l'aura conférée par ses victoires et
poursuivre la lutte
mais charles vii privilégie la
négociation avec philippe le banc durant
le mois d'août malgré la division
l'armée du sacre progresse elle atteint
compiègne puis saint denis ville symbole
avec sa nécropole des rois de france
paris est tout proche
la pucelle donnent l'assaut 8 septembre
14 929 les assaillants et suit lé feu de
l'artillerie parisienne la taxe se
poursuit jusqu'au soir mais c'est un
échec
janet blessé par un carreau d'arbalète
et son porte étendard tués pourtant elle
veut reprendre les hostilités avec eux
charles vii à l'origine est surnommé
l'indolent bon il finira sa carrière en
étant sûr nommé charles vii le
victorieux mais pour l'instant c'est
l'indolent il hésite il tergiverse et
puis cette jeune femme l'inquiète un peu
il se dit tous mes officiers sont
impressionnés donc il la libère alors
que l'armée du sacré déjà divisé charles
7la démobilise totalement le 21
septembre 14 129
il négocie une trêve avec philippe lebon
leroy redonne la priorité à la
diplomatie après avoir joué la carte de
la fougue et de la passion jeanne d'arc
après le couronnement de chars le 7 va
officiellement perdre son commandement
le commandement des troupes mais elles
continuent elles toujours avec eux d'une
petite milice la pucelle essuie un
nouvel échec à la charité sur loire
elle ne peut dissimuler son impatience
au printemps lorsque philippe lebon
semble entamer une offensive
elle repart en campagne sans l'accord de
chars le 7
lors des dernières négociations le roi a
cédé compiègne au duc de bourgogne
or les habitants de la cité refuse de se
soumettre
c'est en voulant leur porter secours que
jane est capturé par les bourguignons
le 23 mai 14 130 elle n'a que 18 ans
charles vii ne va rien tenté pour la
récupérer
eh bien oui on sait que ça finit mal
pour la petite jeanne elle est capturée
et par les bourguignons les bourguignons
qui vont la vendre aux anglais ils vont
la vendre aux anglais je me suis amusé à
calculer
pour combien pour quelle somme est bien
pour cent vingt mille de nos euros
tout simplement
après quatre mois de captivité aux mains
des bourguignons en octobre jal est
transféré à rouen où va se tenir son
procès même s'il n'y a pas d'agent
secret à ce moment là on sait que le roi
charles vii espère entre compiègne et
rouen faire envoyer quelques troupes
pour faire un coup de force pour
récupérer la petite jeanne d'arc
si bien que les anglais vont passer par
des chemins détournés vont remonter vers
la manche vers le crotoy on arrivait à
eux et ensuite redescendre sur roy et
charles vii n'intervient pas parce que
il se dit si je prends trop sans doute
se dit il sa position pour jeanne d'arc
je serai mal placé pour négocier ensuite
avec les anglais le procès de jeanne
d'arc débute en février 14 à 131 le
tribunal se compose de 42 membres et les
premières séances sont publiques
c'est l'évêque de beauvais qui va
prendre les choses en main monseigneur
cochon est un cochon
enfin ces crises et à uzerche oen qui va
lui faire son procès et qui aux ordres
des anglais va absolument vouloir la
condamner pourtant cette petite tout
jeune femme qui est a priori les traits
qui n'a pas reçu une éducation en
faculté ou ailleurs et bien lui répond
du tac au tac bec et ongles on a les
pièces du procès c'était étonnant quand
cochon lui et dont jeanne pourquoi est
ce que dieu aime les anglais elle lui
répond oui quand ils sont chez eux il ya
plusieurs volumes qui raconte le procès
mais les paroles de jeanne d'arc sont
toujours un peu déformé parce qu on les
reprend dans la forme juridique
elle a vraisemblablement c'était
quelqu'un de très simple elle n'a pas
parlé le langage châtié compliqué qu'on
lui prête dans les comptes rendus de son
procès en mars
les interrogatoires se poursuivent dans
sa cellule avec un nombre restreint de
juge
il conserve 12 chefs d'accusation parmi
les 70 réuni initialement contre elle
comme elle porte des habits d'homme et
prétend être guidé par une puissance
divine on la suspecte d'hérésie la
plupart des théologiens préconise de
s'en remettre au pape
mais le temps presse pour les anglais
qui entendent mettre un terme à
l'histoire de cette puce elle qui sème
le doute dans leurs rangs
[Musique]
le processus s'accélère avec l'aide de
l'université de paris jeanne doit se
soumettre ou son sort sera confiée à la
justice anglaise le 24 mai une mise en
scène l'attend dans l'un des cimetières
de rouen devant une foule de plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont lu somme de
renoncer à ses croyances et à ses
pratiques
si elle refuse elle sait que c'est le
bûcher qui l'attend peut-être est-il
déjà préparé jeanne se soumet et reprend
des habits de femme il y avait tout tout
tout s'est tu
tout ce basculement entre personnes qui
est monté porté au pinacle et puis tout
d'un coup parce qu elle est prisonnière
d'un n'a pas finalement elle n'a pas de
lien avec le ciel et comme disait
l'historien jacques le goff elle avait
perdu son charisme
[Musique]
habillé en femme dans sa tour à rosas
tour du prisonnier la tornade et bien
les soldats anglais vont essayer de la
violente est tout simplement si bien
qu'elle va se rhabiller en sommes et à
ce moment-là l'évêque cauchon la
condamnant luisant voilà vous êtes
revenu vous êtes parjure vous êtes
relapse
vous êtes hérétiques et relapse vous
êtes une sorcière le 30 mai 14 131 sur
la place du marché de rouen
jeanne d'arc à peine sortis de
l'adolescence et brûlées vives
on dit aussi les romanciers historique
dit aussi qu'elle n'a pas été brûlée
qu'elle réapparaît plus tard sous le nom
de jeanne des armoises or c'est faux on
sait que son confesseur le petit moine
martin la venue était là devant elle lui
tendait le crucifix pour le premier feu
car il ya eu trois feux le premier feu
pour l'asphyxier
le deuxième feu pour la consumer et le
troisième pour réduire tout en cendres
au maximum et ensuite jeter les cendres
dans la scène du haut du pont qui porte
toujours son nom aujourd'hui
la réconciliation officielle entre le
roi de france et le duc de bourgogne ars
à 114 135 marque la fin de la guerre
civile commençait en 407 entre armagnacs
et bourguignons l'alliance anglo
bourguignonne est rompu et s'amorce
alors un changement radical dans les
rapports de force
cette paix d'arras permettent à charles
vii de reconquérir deux ans plus tard
paris qui redevient la capitale du cap
essien et où s'installe de nouveau la
cour royale
peu à peu les territoires du nord de la
loire pas sous l'autorité française et
seul trouble notoire de cette période
faste incombe aux fils de charles vii le
futur louis 11 qui participent à 14 140
à une révolte de grands seigneurs
sévèrement réprimée l'apra gris la
guerre de cent ans s'est poursuivie bien
au delà de la mort de jeanne d'arc
l'épopée johanniques a été très courte
elle a duré à peu près deux ans et elle
s'est achevé par la mort de jeanne d'arc
en 1431 donc après la mort de jeanne
d'arc le roi de france a mis plus de
vingt ans pour reconquérir le reste du
royaume de france et notamment pour
rentrer à rouen qui est le lieu où
jeanne d'arc a été brûlé
en 14 143 de nouvelles figures féminines
fait son entrée dans la vie de charles
vii
agnès sorel elle a 21 ans lui 40
rien ne prédestine alors cette petite
demoiselle d'honneur à une vie fabuleuse
si ce n'est sa grande beauté charles cet
invisible
mon dieu comme elle est belle et il lui
a fait une cour effrénée et elle est
devenue la première maîtresse officielle
le l'histoire de france jusqu alors le
roi pouvait d'avoir les maîtresses mais
qu'il camouflait où on l'ignorait
personne n'en parlait là elle est
affichée elle est exposée
c'est la maîtresse officielle il est
vrai que c'est qu'une beauté c'est une
star on a des tableaux d'elle de fouquet
la représentant en vierge à l'enfant
avec la poitrine à l'air ne sont pas des
saints sont des obus on comprend que le
roi ait craqué devant une telle beauté
que les deux personnages vont se
rencontrer en 14 143 et charles vii pour
la garder à ses côtés va la mettre au
service de sa propre femme marie danjou
ils vont vivre une idylle 1 durant six
années pendant ces six années agnès
sorel donnera quatre filles à charles
vii au contact d'agnès sorel le roi de
naturel renfrognée solitaire change de
comportement
la belle devient indispensable au
souverain qui n'hésite pas à
l'officialiser à la cour éclipsant la
reine marie danjou irritant le dauphin
future wii u 11 qui ne supporte pas de
voir sa mère ainsi bafoué
agnès impose la mode à la cour
décolletés provocants épaules nues ob à
longue traîne
charles vii ébloui la comble de saveurs
et de bijoux elle avait découverte de
diamant de pierreries on a taillé pour
elle le premier solitaire a été taillé
dans l'histoire de diamants tripous
agnès sorel il va l'enrichir
considérablement en lui offrant des
présents magnifique que ce soit des
pierres précieuses ou bien des
seigneuries des domaines également
on parle du château de beauté sur marne
d'où le surnom d'agnès sorel de la dame
de beauté intéressés par les produits
nouveaux du commerce
la favorite côtoient l'ambition jacques
coeur le grand argentier du roi certains
disent même d'un peu trop près
initiateur de l'import export entre la
france et d'orient il est devenu
immensément riche
bon qui avertit auprès des noble
désargenté
ils prêtent de l'argent contre leurs
biens immobiliers et devient alors
propriétaires de terres et de châteaux
dans tout le royaume à bourges il fait
construire un véritable palais en
architecture gothique tardive
préfigurant la renaissance principal
conseiller du roi
il réorganise les finances établi une
monnaie forte et stable qui permet une
spectaculaire relance économique
bientôt synonyme de financement d'une
guerre de reconquête
c'est agnès sorel qui convainc chars le
7 de repartir en guerre
le 31 juillet 14 249 afin de reprendre
la normandie encore sous domination
anglaise et agnès sorel l'à beaucoup
aidé parce que elle lui a dit un jour
vous savez je suis allé voir mon mon
tireurs de khartoum ont astrologue qui
m'a dit que je serai en effet la
maîtresse du plus grand roi ben de
l'europe mais ça ne peut être vous
puisque les anglais sont toujours sur le
territoire de la normandie et ailleurs
donc c'est certainement droit
d'angleterre
j'ai donc allé rendre visite au roi
d'angleterre car le set a été vexé piqué
au vif et il a levé les armées et il a
libéré notamment la normandie des armées
du roi d'angleterre
charles vii s'attaque donc à la
normandie et au littoral aquitain en
deux batailles formi en 14 250 et
castillon
en 14 253 l'artillerie française fait
oublier un siècles d'humiliation en
broyant les archers anglais seul calais
reste anglaise la guerre de cent ans
s'achève et charles vii est devenu un
souverain puissant et respecté
mais entre temps il a perdu sa belle
favorite
alors elle bondit elle vendit en
normandie à jumièges où il avait son
quartier général et au mesnil sous
jumièges on est en février et la
traversée depuis son château de loches
quant à des propriétaires elle a
traversé toute la france dans le froid
dans les frimas à cheval eh eh bien elle
souffre énormément au moment de d'un
accouchement prématuré
et elle va mourir elle va mourir en
mettant mon son quatrième enfant
agnès sorel meurt à 28 ans l'infection
mal endiguée et de l'ingestion de sels
de mercure qui interroge sur un éventuel
empoisonnement
on sait depuis peu que cette norme
semble pas naturel parce que certains
médecins se sont penchés sur sa
dépouille que l'on a retrouvée à loches
dans dans sa sépulture et on a constaté
que cette dépouille contenait un taux de
mercure absolument invraisemblable de
quoi tuer un boeuf pratiquement elle est
donc morte empoisonnée au mercure alors
la question se pose est-ce un
empoisonnement volontaire c'est à dire
un crime ou est ce un accident de
médecine parce que on sait qu'elle se
soigne et abondamment au mercure pour
tuer le tout les vermines des intestins
les askar yaws etc etc
et puis aussi parce que le mercure
apaiser les douleurs de l'accouchement
or elle était en plein accouchement
alors il est question que l'on a dit que
lou lyon 11 qui était le fils de charles
vii dont lyon n'avait pas supporté du
tout la présence de cette maîtresse
auprès de son papa et l'aurait fait en
voisin née dans ce cas là il n'a pas pu
le faire seule parce que louis 11
n'était pas à jumièges au moment de la
mort mais il aurait comment dirais-je
soudoyer le médecin le docteur le poids
de 20 qui aurait donné une dose de
mercure considérable à la parturiente
qui en seraient mortes charles vii a
voulu comme pour une reine de france
agnès sorel bénéficient de deux tombeaux
l'un pour son coeur à jumièges donc le
gisant à jumièges s'y trouvent toujours
l'autre pour son corps à loches alias
sort elle souhaitait être enterrée dans
le choeur de la collégiale saint-ours
donc dans la cité royale de loches ce
fut le cas elle l avait fait un don aux
chanoines de saint-ours pour que soit
dit des messes en son nom par contre les
chanoines n'était pas forcément d'accord
avec le statut social qui lui avait été
conféré ce n'était pas véritablement une
reine ce n'était qu'une maîtresse et
donc les chanoines se sont adressés aux
différents rois de france qui se sont
succédé en demandant le déplacement du
gisant de la belle agnès ils ont obtenu
grâce auprès du roi louis saez la mort
d'agnès sorel dont on rend responsable
son ami jacques coeur précipite la chute
du grand argentier
il est arrêté en 14 151 condamné à mort
puis au bannissement
il réussit à s'échapper de sa prison de
poitiers et s'enfuit à rome pour se
mettre au service du pape
c'est à l'apogée de sa gloire et alors
qu'il continue à pleurer agnès sorel que
charles 7 prend enfin le temps de
réfléchir à ce qu'il pourrait faire pour
la mémoire de jeanne d'arc
la nouvelle du miracle d'orléans s'est
diffusé dans une france pourtant exemple
jeanne d'arc icône de son vivant bascule
ainsi de l'histoire à la légende se
métamorphose en véritable personnage
patrimonial dont la mission évoluera au
fil des siècles
en quatorze 156 charles vii ordonne un
nouveau procès pour réhabiliter la
pucelle
[Musique]
il faut quand même montré un peu de
reconnaissance parce qu'autrement c'est
l'image de charles vii qui sera altérée
on dira que une reconnaît pas celle qui
l'a fait roi
on va rester au nez refaire un procès et
puis jeanne sera en effet blanchi de
tout soupçon mais il faudra attendre la
fin du 19ème et le 20ème pour qu'elle
puisse monter sur les hôtels et devenir
la patronne de la française jeanne d'arc
un troisième procès celui de la
canonisation fait de jeunes une sainte
nous sommes en 1920 et toutes les
églises de france lui font alors une
place au milieu des icônes qu'elle
adorait jeanne d'arc est devenue sainte
très tard on aurait pu imaginer qu'elle
soit canonisé dès le xvème siècle mais
ça ne pouvait pas être le cas dans la
mesure où elles avaient été condamnées
par l'église en 14 131
même si elle a été réhabilitée en 14 156
l'église n'aime pas revenir sur ces
jugements et par conséquent il a fallu
attendre la fin du 19e siècle pour que
sa cause soit introduite auprès du saint
siège et simplement 1920 pour qu'elle
soit canonisé
il faut savoir qu'on dispose que d'une
seule image de jeune d'arc exécuté de
son vivant et c'est un petit croquis
exécuté par un greffier du parlement de
paris
on n'a pas d'autres images de jeunes
d'armes de son vivant ce détail fait que
l'image de jeanne d'arc où l'image qu'on
nous donne de jeanne d'arc a varié au
cours des siècles la première image de
jeanne d'arc véhiculée par les partisans
de charles vii et celle de la bergère de
domrémy incarnant pauvreté et simplicité
la femme de lettres christine de pisan à
travers son poème le dit tier 2 g and
dark composé juste après les premiers
exploits de la petite paysanne exalte
l'image de l'héroïne épique
on a par exemple aux xviie et au xviiie
siècle l'image d'une héroïne très
féminine presque une courtisane habillés
avec des robes avec des cheveux longs et
bouclés et qui porte souvent un élégant
chapeau à plumes qui est en fait son
panache le symbole de la victoire
à l'époque ce n'est qu' à la fin du 19e
siècle que jeanne d'arc va acquérir une
image un petit peu plus militaire et
c'est sans doute lié au conflit et
notamment à celui de 1870 où elle est
davantage représentés en armure intégral
et avec des cheveux courts figure
historique devenue une héroïne nationale
jeanne d'arc pourvoyeuse d'idéaux de
rassemblement et de liberté revêt une
dimension symbolique et identitaire
jeanne d'arc est devenu l'image de la
résistance en quelque sorte alors la
résistance qu'elle soit la résistance
des campagnes où qu'elle soit la
résistance des cités mais c'est l'image
de résistance et et juste après la
première guerre mondiale quand il a
fallu précisément redorer le blason
français
et bien c'est jeanne d'arc qui a été
choisi en raison de son rôle pendant la
guerre de cent ans et notamment lors de
la bataille d'orléans également parce
qu'elle a été brûlé par les anglais le
personnage de jeanne d'arc a été
utilisés par la suite pour stigmatiser
l'église par exemple pendant la période
anticlérical autour de 1905 mais
également pour stigmatiser les onglets
par le gouvernement de vichy en 1941
femme idéale martyrs brûlée vive à 19
ans chef de guerre aux saintes canonisé
l'image de jeanne d'arc est mise au
service des idéaux parfois
contradictoires qui revendique son
héritage
au fil du temps les nouvelles missions
qu'on attribue à l'icône révèle toute la
fascination pour ce personnage sur
lequel on greffe aujourd'hui encore
toute sorte de passion
le règne de charles vii a permis de
mettre un terme à la guerre de cent ans
les anglais ne possède plus que calais
sur le sol français
s'il faut attendre le traité de
picquigny en 14 275 pour entériner cette
paix charles vii laisse néanmoins à son
fils louis 11 un royaume fort et
consolidé
[Musique]
quand charles vii va finir par mourir
pour laisser la place à son fils le
dauphin lyon bien lyon va hériter un
royaume qui n'est pas en mauvais état du
tout parce que l'intégrité territoriale
et est belle il a réussi à vraiment
avoir des frontières intéressante
ensuite il a créé des manières de
parlement il a créé une monnaie qui est
assez saine le pays est devenu un pays
en voie de modernité et son fils louis
11 achèvera précisément d'en faire une
puissance moderne
jeanne d'arc et agnès sorel ont tout de
montrer à leur manière un dévouement
sans faille au roi charles vii qui leur
doit sans aucun doute d'être un roi à
victorieux
[Musique]